The other day, my family mailed me a bike helmet from Amazon.
We used two-day shipping, and when the package arrived, it was essentially a cardboard box
nesting doll.
I had to cut my way through three different boxes in order to get to the helmet, which
is especially ridiculous when you consider that a helmet is specifically designed to withstand
and damp.
With the holiday season fast approaching, which in the US means a rush of last minute Amazon
prime orders just like mine, I feel it's important to look at the exact effect this new world
of online shopping and instant shipping has on climate change.
The carbon footprint of online shopping greatly depends on the actions of consumers.
As a 2013 MIT study shows, shoppers can be divided into a number of different categories
that span from a traditional retail shopper to what the study calls a cybernotch shopper,
who exclusively shops online.
The study shows that online shopping with slower shipping options has a smaller footprint
than driving to a retail store to search, purchase, and return a product.
The highest impact shopper is actually a mix of both.
One that goes to the store to compare prices and then buys online with expedited shipping.
The majority of the reason why traditional shoppers have such a large footprint is that
they're using a car to reach these brick and mortar shops.
So if they take public transportation, bike, or even walk, they're footprint plumbers.
As for people who shop online, when they choose shipping options like two-day mailing,
they are more than doubling their transportation-related emissions,
especially within the last couple of years as companies like Amazon have started to send
vans out to deliver packages that are only half full in order to fulfill customer expectations.
This ultimately means more emissions because trucks and vans have to make multiple trips
between hubs and homes, as opposed to slower shipping options which fill up trucks with cargo
and make a single trip to fill orders. Packaging also has a significant role to play
when it comes to environmental impact. Often when you select the two-day shipping option,
the products that you want aren't bundled together in the same box because they are usually
coming from two different facilities across the country. As a result, you receive a new cardboard
box for every product you purchase. And the carbon emissions of products are on average 35% more
when shipped separately than when shipped together. In addition, many products are packaged
inefficiently. A study conducted by a peerless research group found that on average boxes contain
20% of wasted space, which shipping facilities then fill with paper, styrofoam, or bubble wrap,
ultimately creating more waste which finds its way into waterways or landfills.
But there are many options on both the retail and consumer side that could help lower emissions.
For companies, cutting down emissions means nudging shoppers towards slower shipping options
or making in-store purchases when appropriate. It can also mean bundling items together in one package
or even reducing the amount of packaging for a product by right sizing its box.
But as individuals, we also have choices to make. For one, if it's possible,
find a way to get to your local retail store without using a car. You'll not only drastically
lower your footprint, but Shopping Local also gives you the opportunity to connect with other people
face to face, which helps build community resilience in the long run. If you don't have that luxury,
consider using slower shipping options, which allows the online retailer to optimize shipping
routes because they don't have to rush to get the item onto your doorstep. This essentially means
fewer miles traveled for trucks and planes because they can fill up with packages and only leave
when they're full. Online Shopping isn't something to be demonized. It's an important resource for
folks who may not be able to shop in person for a variety of reasons. However, it's important to
think critically about our individual relationships with online shopping. I know I say this a lot,
but think before you shop. That online shopping spree not only has negative consequences for your
wallet, but it also has lasting effects on the natural world we've come to rely on.
Thanks so much for watching. If you've enjoyed the videos I've been putting out lately,
consider clicking the subscribe button down below and hitting the little bell next to it.
Or if you're feeling generous, the number one thing you could do to help this channel out
is to support it on Patreon. Again, thank you so much for watching and I will see you in two weeks.